while Eisenhower said the greatest of
leaders are the ones smart enough to
hire people smarter than them so that's
the first thing you do you got to get
four or five people that's smarter than
you you guys have to work together you
guys have to you know start from the
bottom think about all the good ideas
and think about all the bad ideas and if
the good outweighs the bad then you
should go with if the bad always good
and you should probably think about
something else but that's always been my
philosophy and I've guys that are very
intelligent very smart work for me with
my ideas their intelligence my
intelligence has been working out pretty
good so far it's not a dictatorship as a
leader but I take input from everybody
like hey I don't think we should do this
or any I think it's a good idea so
you're most of time I am kind of voting
without going to the voting process so
let's just say it's five of us and three
says I don't think we should do it too
says we should do it probably won't do
it but you know when you're on the team
when you have to do everything
collaboratively and you know sometimes
you're not going to get along and
sometimes you're going to have argument
but the respect factor is always there
and I'll you know as long as you respect
each other you know treat everyone with
respect and you know just listen to
everybody's views I thought it was okay
you know what one of my favorite books
is the one minute manager so you know
when i'm listening to my guys first
thing is I don't like like I know it all
so I hear suggestions I put in my
suggestions we have a couple meetings
and then we just iron it out and we just
figure it out I learn every day you know
but you know the good thing this that
has brought me along the ways another
win championships are not to build teams
I've great teammates surrounding me so
anytime I get into a venture most of
time we know what we're doing and if
it's a problem we figured out as a team
you